[Música]
y volvemos con las noticias económicas
de la mano de nuestra periodista Daniela
hablando Daniela bienvenida de regreso
por tercera vez hoy en directo América
me apoderé de este estudio se apoderó de
este estudio y aprovechemos entonces su
presencia para hablar de Microsoft y del
chatbot que lanzó porque la novedad es
que llegará a los teléfonos móviles pues
mire el chatbot de esta empresa se llama
Bing hace menos de una semana realizó
correcciones importantes para evitar que
este motor de búsqueda artificialmente
inteligente se salga de control como ya
se ha visto en algunas pruebas el
gigante tecnológico dijo que traerá este
chatbot a su aplicación para teléfonos
inteligentes así como para su navegador
Edge coloque quiere ponerse al frente de
Google que todavía no tiene un chat de
este tipo Aunque quienes quieran usarlo
este es Microsoft deben apuntarse en una
larga lista de espera bueno Y usted ya
lo ensayó cuéntenos cómo funciona bueno
en pocas semanas de haberse lanzado como
piloto más de un millón de usuarios lo
han probado yo estoy incluida Microsoft
dice que la mayoría respondió
positivamente pero que otros
descubrieron que Bing los estaba
insultando también declarándoles su amor
o expresando otro lenguaje perturbador o
inclusive extraño pero la firma dice que
está ya corrigió estos errores y que
ahora funciona perfectamente por ejemplo
si su familia está conversando sobre una
próxima reunión dice la empresa
simplemente se le puede pedir a Bing que
de sugerencias sobre destinos de viaje
pronósticos meteorológicos y eventos
interesantes en la época de este viaje
de esta manera todos los participantes
del chat van a tener acceso a lo que
diga Bing ellos verán si le creen o no
como quien dice ustedes una en un millón
una en un millón Sí señora Muy bien
Daniela pasemos más noticias económicas
porque los ministros de finanzas del g20
están haciendo su segundo día en India
donde se están reuniendo y el anuncio es
que Estados Unidos es bastante alentador
frente a los pronósticos económicos del
año claro el discurso más esperado de
este evento que se termina el sábado era
justamente el de Jane yelen la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
ella dijo que hoy la economía está mejor
de lo que se preveía hace unos meses y
también llamó a que se intensifique el
apoyo financiero de kiev a través de
mecanismos como el fondo monetario
internacional de hecho esperan negociar
un crédito de 15 mil millones de dólares
Próximamente para la jefa económica del
gobierno de biden se debe también
ejercer más presión contra Rusia por
medio de sanciones
tal y como lo veo nuestras sanciones han
tenido un efecto negativo muy
significativo en Rusia hasta ahora
si bien según algunas mediciones la
economía rusa se ha mantenido mejor de
lo que inicialmente se esperaba Rusia
Ahora tiene un déficit presupuestario
significativo
Daniela se puede decir que una de las
noticias Dentro de este discurso de
hielo en Es que casi que por primera vez
Estados Unidos reconoce que las
sanciones económicas de occidente contra
Rusia no han afectado tanto la economía
de Moscú como se esperaba claro y este
si nos vamos a las cifras al comienzo de
la guerra se creía que el producto
interno bruto iba a caer más del 10% en
Rusia pero lo hizo en poco más del 2%,
sin embargo sí hay que decir que sus
ingresos han caído drásticamente
Mientras que el déficit presupuestario
va en ascenso pero para ver el impacto
de estas sanciones también hay que
remitirse a los sectores específicos
como el actriz los rusos están teniendo
que acudir al mercado del usado que ya
representa más del 75% de lo que se
vende mientras que la cantidad de autos
nuevos se desplomó en casi 60% el año
pasado bueno Y ahora sí vamos con las
cifras del día los indicadores que
tenemos para hoy Bueno pues María Clara
hoy las bolsas todas estaban
reaccionando a las minutas de la reserva
Federal dadas a conocer ayer y esta
reacción fue mixta por ejemplo hacia
Cerro con pérdidas lideradas por Japón
después de que el Banco Central de
Estados Unidos advirtiera que está
dispuesto a seguir subiendo las tasas de
interés si es necesario porque la
desaceleración de la inflación todavía
no es suficiente como para frenar ese
ascenso de tasas en Europa también
operan mayormente a la baja antes del
cierre tras conocerse que la inflación
anual en los 20 países de la zona Euro
fue del 8,6% en enero un pequeño alivio
porque en diciembre había sido del 9
ciento Gracias Daniela por toda la
información económica de hoy los
invitamos mañana al especial sobre
Ucrania también en economía vamos a
estar ahí pendientes